[Music]
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor
but with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
maybe a new home could be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish he'd get into some trouble
there's still time
what are you doing here in somerville
anyway we're completely broke and our
grandfather left us this creepy old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on you're
saying he left us nothing
well i wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here
somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason
are you troubled by strange noises in
the middle of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
you guys hear that
something's coming
all city
took the walking dead
we're closed
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure we have to push the
boundaries take the risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run do it now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of me
[Music]
the city wants to kill you
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
other half wants to control you hey dr
mike you and i should stay in touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
oh there's kids dr michael morvious at
your services
[Applause]
you have any idea what those markers are
they look pretty ancient
the tracks end here definitely bravo
team they don't just disappear
where the hell are we
that lightning it hit those markers and
it took us somewhere
guys
so what are we like guardians of the
galaxy now
on our six
yeah bros
did you see that thing
this is officially above my pay grade
i don't care
what those creatures are
you destroy them
and close the gateway
all right
this is our only chance
we have to take
[Music]
we need kong
the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child
she's the only one he'll communicate
with
i knew that they had a bond
she had nowhere to go so
i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way
khan did the same
[Music]
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
these are dangerous times
godzilla's out there and he's hurting
people and we don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here the same opinion
the myths are real yeah
[Music]
and they're the last ones standing
no one
[Music]
[Music]
a bomb
i think
[Music]
i don't know why he came all the way up
here
there's nothing left
there are people out there
people worth saving
most people had finally given up hope
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
what is storytelling
storytelling started with our indigenous
people
can anyone give me an example of a myth
or a story
they're afraid of
lucas
what's going on
we found a part of a man in the woods
today
part of the man
i guess the other half was found in the
mine
oh this has got to be an animal right
[Music]
no animal that i've ever seen
something is going on with lucas
these drawings belong to a student of
mine
this is what was in the mind
[Music]
it's a diabolical spirit
excuse me this is a myth
for you yeah
he is my responsibility
he's here
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil
why are you back here clear your
conspiracies weren't true when we were
kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this i'm afraid claire i'm afraid
of what they're gonna do to this town
see umbrella they have an incident i'm
talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
people are getting sick
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
25 years
[Music]
split up
[Music]
[Music]
we gotta get out of here
[Music]
we're gonna take umbrella down
[Applause]
don't move let me see it don't move amy
let's see it okay
ready
i love it that's super sweet because
it's terrible
[Music]
oh my god
where have you been joel amy i love you
i'm gonna come find you
the day of the monster uprising
was the day i lost everyone
only a small fraction of humanity
survived to move than around
i've been scanning for amy the entire
time
and now i finally found her oh hey joe
amy is that you oh my god hey
how far away is amy's colony
85 miles it's an impossible journey
everything will try to kill you
don't fight just run and hide
uh
okay
you really got me going you got me
you're all alone me too you don't have
to talk about it me though you wanna
come with me
is that a samurai sword yeah yes it is
listen to your instincts out here man
what if i have terrible instincts
[Music]
you'll die
super encouraging speech
you made it all this way for a girl huh
do you ever hear the term fools
no amy i miss you so much
we have lost this wall
we could still take our world back
you're more of a survivor than i thought
[Music]
lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
you live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can fix it
again
you
[Music]
i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
cletus why me that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
discarnate
oh [ __ ]
where you going
that is a red one you need to come out
right now
i will let you eat everybody i promise
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples
[Music]
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land and you're descending seven
miles to the bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
this
[Music]
on a scale from one to ten how bad's my
rig
we drilled to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station
how do we even get there we walk
we're just gonna walk with insufficient
oxygen across the bottom of the ocean i
don't know what's out there
worst idea ever
[Music]
almost death turn your lights off
what is that what is that
what is happening
there's something following us
hey all you shark week fans out there
welcome back it's our third summer here
at little happy an abandoned fishing
village in the mozambique channel
sharks return here each year their home
like ours is under attack from climate
change
emma what's wrong
a half dozen people went missing about
100 miles up the orange river
turns out it was bull sharks
so what do we do
[Music]
there is a boy in the field
[Music]
brown where are you
there he is
those sharks have been altered engineer
they're not sharks
climate change is making them highly
aggressive towards everything
it's all about survival folks
that was close
ah
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts and estevians are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Applause]
[Music]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived
is because you're a very uncommon girl
you're not alone
not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time
rain
i was 13
i thought it was a dream
i just lost control
sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto
my girlfriend a partner
ileana i killed 18 men one by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place
takes your greatest fear
it makes you live through it
until it kills you
[Music]
who's there
we can get out of this
together
[Applause]
[Music]
you